[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport l'émission ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux du sport local
yvelinois vous connaissez le programme
de cette émission il y aura comme
d'habitude des analyses des débats et
des duels avec la crème de la crème des
chroniqueurs sportifs du département
aujourd'hui ils sont cinq
autour de la table présentation en
musique on commence par une gueule un
caractère sa personnalité il a façonné
au rythme des mêlées de rugby son sport
de prédilection lite également amateur
de golf on le surnomme dans cette
émission le à gladiator pierre
chevallier du rugby-club de versailles
est avec nous dans cette émission
quand allez-vous byers à lui michael
après une présentation comme celle-là
super bien force et honneur toujours en
forme toujours en pleine forme
le réalisateur est il prêt à frapper il
est prêt à combattre dans l'arène c'est
parti on verra ça on continue à ma
gauche un musical nous vient tout droit
de versailles sinon des françaises les
plus doués en pole dance
un sport qui mêle danse acrobatique
autour d'une barre à elle va une
nouvelle fois faire chavirer tous les
coeurs dans cette émission
notre ambassadrice de charme hélène de
la grange est avec nous pendant une
heure bonjour bonjour élèves je suis
ravi de revenir d'espagne je sors en
bout ne s'est pas là la semaine dernière
on a reçu des mails et des mails pour
nour et de tourcoing est ce que j'avais
une réponse à leur apporter à vos fans
non il faut cultiver le mystère en plein
l esra cultivant ce schéma dit de
retenue pas trop j'espère on repasse de
l'autre côté à musique c'est le einstein
du sport local le newton du 78 qui vient
tout juste de sortir de son laboratoire
évinois pour venir sur ce plateau et
nous de rap
encore une fois le son de sport dans ce
talk le professeur frederick henderson
le directeur sportif des templiers
d'elancourt est avec nous toujours aussi
élégant merci avec personne alors on
essaye est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
donner là sont une nouvelle fois
toujours toujours supervisé bien étudié
comme d'habitude toujours on repasse à
ma gauche musique c'est un monument les
gens
hamilton de cette émission et du rugby
local en général sont humeau et
déroutant ses frasques sont à chaque
fois enregistrés dans pour le best-of de
fin d'année dans cette émission coach
jean nice ex entraîneur de plaisir est
avec nous bonjour coach et au jour quand
allez-vous bonjour à tous est ce qu'ils
avaient prévu des envolées lyriques pour
cette émission alors maillage et un
rotor alors le dernier que nouveau il
vous dit que je suis en retard nicolas
justin eu dans l'indivision mais je suis
pas en retard
par contre moi j'suis pas cessé au fil
au fil de l'émission on termine à ma
droite par un petit nouveau musique
c'est un spécialiste du cyclisme vient
tout droit du vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
la baril donnent des baptêmes sur la
liste mais aujourd'hui c'est son baptême
dans nos studios
jean françois guilbault elle est avec
nous pour sa grange dirai merci de
m'accueillir
jean-françois grande première du coup
pour vous comment vous sentez vous tout
semble bon j'ai le trac bien sûr parce
que traque parce que je suis avec le
temps fans de légende du sport en
illinois
j'ai mis un petit cadeau dont ça va
aller ok avant de passer au programme de
cette édition nous allons parler
handball plaisir a signé l'exploit du
week-end du 4 mars dans les yvelines
en nationale 3 les plaisirs wa deuxième
du championnat ont réussi à renverser le
leader saint polois dans leur gymnase
lors de la 13e journée
une victoire acquise avec brio 28 à 21
dans une ambiance électrique
un résultat qui leur permet de pointer à
un petit point de la première place et
de la montée on écoute l'entraîneur du
club victor garnier
vraiment vraiment un gros moment très
très bon niveau des retombées univers
oui ça je n'ai aucun doute là dessus le
père tombé peut-être manière l'armée par
un moment donné et avec une telle
manière pas vraiment une réaction autour
de cette table sur cette victoire ferait
qu anderson
on l'avait dit leur préférence aux idées
donc ça fait plaisir de voir qu'ils ont
pu rebondir de 10 derniers matchs qui
s'était joué sur le fil et j'espère que
ça les hacher massira d'alain minutes ça
ressemble à une vraie aventure de groupe
un groupe qui secret ils montent ils
sont mon temps ils perdent de peu contre
massy qui était de quitter le troisième
est là en avant on avait déjà sulfuré
est supputé qu'il puisse l'emporter
alors ils font ils font un bon bout de
chemin dans cette poule et tout bonheur
qu'on leur souhaite c'est justement de
continuer de se maintenir en haut de
cette poule 28 21
à la surprise sur ce match oui un match
un match c'est un match et il a ils ont
simplement confirmé mais qu'il fallait
compter avec eux et qui sont en haut du
tableau en haut du tableau et que
c'était simplement le résultat c'est ce
qu'on avait dit la saison n'est pas
terminée
c'était un résultat sur le fil il avait
perdu sur le fil
là ils ont montré qu'ils étaient
largement la hauteur et largement il
avait largement leur place pour monter
ddd cette saison au niveau supérieur
donc pas de surprise pour moi hélène
28-21 c'est un score large quand même
pour un match comme celui là oui c'était
le premier contre le deuxième
voilà il ya quand même un écart après ça
ça donne suffisamment de confiance pour
continuer à aller de l'avant et du coup
confirmé un peu cette montée là il
montre enfin ils savent s'imposer très
bien jean françois est ce qu'ils ont
fait le plus dur
beaux scores de rugby est ce qu'ils ont
fait le plus dur ils ont fait le plus
dur mais avait continué maintenant il
faut continuer à s'installer avec un
versailles
oui après peu importe les quartiers sur
ce match là ça joue avant tout aux
nombres de points donc avant de regarder
peut-être l'écart de points parfois lors
qu'il continue à engranger des points au
championnat avant les points au score
pour espérer pouvoir continuer donc
c'est encourageant pour la suite ils ont
ils sont largement à leur place comme
l'a dit jean miss on peut leur souhaiter
que le meilleur pour la suite c'est
vraiment encourageant pour la fin du
championnat
jean ils le restent moi j'ai la moitié
du championnat quasiment pas fait le
plus dur
ils ont simplement montré qu'ils étaient
largement au niveau qu'ils avaient la
possibilité de prétendre à la montée
parce que justement maintenant et puis
depuis le but de la saison de lier par
rapport à leur prestation ils sont
attendus partout donc chaque dimanche
chaque match va être
est pour eux mais se surmonter le
pouvoir parce que tout le monde va
vouloir et battre ça va être l'équipe à
battre
vu qu'ils sont ils se sont positionnés
aujourd'hui comme une sinon la meilleure
équipe de la poule
donc forcément si l'on pas fait le plus
dur ils ont simplement pour moi prouvé
qu'ils étaient largement au niveau de
montée au niveau supérieur
et il faut également qu'ils terminent
premiers pour accéder directement à la
nationale 2 s'ils terminent deuxièmes
ils passent par des barrages faits mais
bon voilà donc donc le championnat est
loin d'être terminé
comme on l'avait dit lors lors de leur
défaite face à massy dans la défaite
dans la victoire vous garder le même cap
ce genre pas du tout c'est simplement
que si c'est pas le cas c'est que le
championnat c'est long et que et qu'on
peut ils peuvent très bien faire un
super match comme ils l'ont fait contre
le contre le premier là où ils ont gagné
largement 28 21
et puis après j'ai fait référence ont
pas face à une équipe qui est du bas de
tableau
parce que dans leur tête c'est pas le
rendez vous c'est pas le c'est pas le
match qui est qui qui font qu'ils
préparent au mieux et ses six sportifs
ça viendrait de décompression selon
voilà il peut y avoir il peut y avoir un
faux pas et ils sont sur le moins ils
sont loin d'être d'être monté encore un
ça sera le mot de la fin sur cette
première thématique on va passer
maintenant au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de rugby
plaisir s'est imposé contre arras et
voit le maintien se profiler nous
évoquerons également la venue de tiger
woods au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines dans le cadre de la ryder
cup
mais avant de développer certaines coup
de projecteur sur le paris nice 2018 qui
s'est déroulé du 4 le 4 et 5 mars dans
les yvelines
[Musique]
du cyclisme pour débuter cette page
résultats et plus précisément la 76e
édition du paris nice pour la 9e année
consécutive le peloton s'est élancé le
dimanche 4 mars depuis là les yvelines
le départ a été donné depuis la ville de
chatou un département qui réussit au
nouveau chouchou du public français
arnaud démare 26 ans qui s'est entraîné
la semaine précédant togo vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
le coureur de la groupama fdj vainqueur
l'année dernière à bois d'arcy s'est de
nouveau illustré en remportant la
première étape au bout du suspense il
devance de quelques millimètres à la
photo finish
l'espagnol gorka izaguirre le sportif
tentera sûrement de réaliser la passe de
3 l'année prochaine
en revenant dans les yvelines au-delà de
l'aspect sportif le paris nice est
également un engouement populaire comme
chaque année les supporters ont répondu
présent pour encourager les 154 coureurs
malgré des conditions climatiques
difficiles
on écoute les aficionados du paris-nice
pas les fautes il est déjà sous la pluie
mais dans tous les cas
les voie rentrer voir le tout
organisation de sa tour
beaucoup de fans c'est un peu la fête du
vélo moi je fais du vélo pour le plaisir
donc puis c'est l'occasion pour les
enfants aussi devoir tout l'équipement
et puis c'est un peu la fête
donc c'est sympa même si c'est vrai que
les conditions météo sont pas sympas un
succès qui ne surprend pas christian
prudhomme le directeur du cyclisme chez
esso on écoute c'est un département qui
est juste à côté de paris paris est là
et en même temps c'est la forêt c'est la
campagne bat qui a tout pour pouvoir
faire du vélo le vélo des champions
comme la bicyclette en famille
tranquillement avec les années
jean-françois gebreel vous êtes d'accord
avec christian prudhomme
oui c'est une belle chose que par eni
spa soit dans les yvelines et que les
yvelinois viennent surtout avec le temps
qu'il a fait d'ailleurs je crois qu'on
va avoir un parler du froid dans le
sport exactement en fin d'émission
ouais je pense que l'on va on va veut
bien en parler donc le lendemain le 5
mars et 10 mois ce sont une nouvelle
fois à déplacer en nombre dans le sud
des yvelines pour le départ de la
deuxième étape depuis or son vilain
village de moins de 400 habitants qui
accueille l'épreuve pour la toute
première fois de son histoire
au total ce sont environ 30000 à 40000
personnes qui ont assisté au paris-nice
sur le département sur les deux jours la
question sur ce thème le cyclisme et il
le sport le plus populaire en france
vous votez oui ou non plus populaire en
france ont fait un petit duel entre vous
et l'année jean-françois aller hélène
conseil après le plus populaire je pense
qu'il n'y a pas un sport qu en première
comment dire en première place mais il
est vraiment dans les plus populaires
peut-être enfin avec d'autres aussi mais
c'est
il rassemble tant au niveau du nombre
d'adhérents que de gens qui se déplacent
pour aller voir
pour moi il fait vraiment partie des
sports un peu familiaux des sports un
peu un peu spectacle on va voir ce qui
se passe les gens sortent ces autres
pour moi il fait partie des sports
phares apprécié par les français
jean françois bouchard vous vous êtes
contre c'est pas con simplement c'est
notre spécialité suis pas d'accord être
le plus populaire parce que avant c'est
vrai que c'était un sport qui étaient
les médias ont fait beaucoup pour que ce
ne soit plus le sport un sport populaire
c'est un sport populaire encore surtout
dans les moments du tour de france
pendant le tour de france paris roubaix
ou là les gens viennent comprenne qu'il
y a qu il ya un engouement mais par les
médias en plus c'est un sport qui est
gratuit c'est à dire que les gens
viennent gratuitement sur les routes et
donc qu'ils assistent gratuitement là je
suis d'accord mais on peut pas dire que
c'est le sport le plus populaire parce
que les médias l'ont un petit peu les
scellés c'est de tomber deux par les
histoires qu'il ya eu 2 par aussi les
difficultés à organiser maintenant sur
les routes
les jeunes ont de moins en moins en
moins de courses à faire et donc
a t'on vive la piste mais c'est vrai que
les routes sont de moins en moins occupé
par l'excès par les cyclistes est de
plus en plus dangereuse fréquents
versailles ou alors vous vous étiez
partager un avant et qu'on était ont été
abordés est ce que c'est le plus je sais
pas si le plus mais c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment un sport populaire et ce qui
est et ce qui est bien avec cet
événement ce explosion de personnes sur
les bords de route
les bords des routes pour le tour de
france 12 millions ça montre bien qu'un
engouement autour de ce sport est ce qu
est ce qui est pas mal à accéder cet
événement là c'est qu'on voit bien que
les yvelines sont une région de sport
une un département où le sport est
populaire peut-être plus que d'entre eux
dans d'autres que dans d'autres régions
france et c'est vrai que ça ça met en
avant que c'est important d'organiser ce
genre d'événement dans les yvelines on
est sûr qu'il y aura un succès populaire
à la clé si on organise un événement de
qualité avec du spectacle pour
intéresser les gens là 30000 à 40000
personnes coincées sur l'appui à l'est
où le froid c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment impressionnant et c'est vrai
que comme le disait hélène c'est
vraiment bien que ça monte ça motive les
gens à s'intéresser à ce qui se passe à
la vie sportive du département pierre
je pense que c'est assez c'est pas le
plus populaire parce qu'il fonctionne
comme comme un peu disait jean françois
parent pic dire que pour le tour de
france comme il peut s'agir de roland
garros pour le tennis c'est en fonction
de l'actualité en fonction de la taille
de l'événement
le tour de france est un élément est un
événement planétaire qui a lieu au début
de l'été il serait vraiment populaire si
c'était vraiment sur toute la durée de
l'année en termes médiatiques en termes
d'adhésion populaire justement avec avec
du monde qui se déplace en fonction des
événements je pense que dans ce concours
en là le football a priori devrait être
plus populaire
si on se passe de ce point de vue là
parce qu'il y en a toute l'année alors
que quelques jours sur le football par
exemple pour le championnat le plus
populaire en europe c'est le championnat
anglais
il y à 13 millions de fans qui se
déplace dans les stades chaque année en
ligue 1 c'est presque 8 millions de
personnes
finalement tour de france voilà en trois
semaines 12 millions d'euros 12 millions
de personnes
plusieurs ne peut être légalement mais
justement c'est le côté c'est le côté je
pense concentration sur le type
d'événement sur le tour de france ou sur
roland garros ou sur la ligue des
champions en football et ce qui fait que
malgré quelques quelques événements qui
tracte un grand nombre de spectateurs et
notamment dans les pires conditions
comme le week-end dernier autour des
routes des yvelines
c'est ça manque on va dire de régularité
dans le dans l'affluence des spectateurs
genre mais moi je crois que tout a été
dit
tout a été dit dans la mesure où chaque
phrase soit à pointer du doigt le côté
gratuité et dans la mesure où c'est
abordable à tout le monde
on vient au bord de la route c'est le
sortie familiale
c'est traditionnel c'est on vient
avec toute modération s'amuser au bord
des routes et puis cliquer avec ce qu'il
faut et puis en même temps je rejoins
aussi pierre lorsqu'il dit que
malheureusement pour cette discipline
c'est pas un championnat surtout de
toute une saison
alors si c'est il ya la saison cyclisme
mais les médias ne nous ne ne ne pointe
que les grandes courses à savoir le tour
de france le paris roubaix et le paris
nice est peut-être le dauphiné libéré
mais a vraiment eu deux mi temps à une
époque oui on parle d'une tentative j'ai
relancé la compétition la coupe de
france il ya mais c'est vrai que les
gens ne se ne s'identifie pas à cette
genre d'épreuve qui dure alors il ya des
classiques mais vous avez des conflits
en bretagne par exemple des grand prix
de plumelec ou des les grands prix de
plouay grand prix de plouay c'est non
mais c'est c'est phénoménal la bosse est
noire de monde mais c'est un peu
confidentielle au niveau du grand public
oui jean françois est ce que on pourrait
un jour faire payer le cycle solaire on
en a parlé d'ailleurs c'est ce que
j'allais répondre à jean c'est que est
ce que si l'on fait payer en bretagne
dans les critériums amateurs on continue
à faire payer la prime du spectateur par
exemple on a en fait payer pour des
critériums les spectateurs et les gens
viennent c'est pas cher c'est 3 ou 5
euros
mais les gens viennent alors cire de
tous deux sur le tour de france je crois
qu'il ya une petite idée hein mais je ne
sais pas si ça se fera
c'était le en revanche c'était le seul
sport qui va aussi loin
en france air vraiment très localement
comme par exemple avoir son avis dans un
tout petit village de 400 habitants
la caravane du tour de france elle passe
par tous les endroits les plus beaux
villages de france à chaque fois avec
différents avec un arrêté exactement
essaie d'aller de ce côté là à la
rencontre des français
du plus petit village à la plus grande
ville puisque ça se termine sur les
champs-elysées à paris pour le tour de
france et c'est là aussi c'est là où il
peut avoir un entretien de l'engouement
populaire silice il y avait peut-être
plus de plus de gros événements tout au
long de l'année ou au moins d'événements
dont on parle et dont on parlerait un
peu plus on passe à notre troisième
thématique on continue ceci en parler
sport part du rugby lors de la 17e
journée de fédérale 2 jouer ce 4 mars
plaisir n'a pas pu briller face au
leader rennes les plaisirs oies ont
lourdement chuté sur leur terrain devant
leur public 59 à 7 dans un match à sens
unique
une défaite logique mais l'essentiel
était ailleurs au mois de février
plaisir à presque validé son ticket pour
une nouvelle saison en fédérale 2 en
venant à bout du premier relégable arras
23 à 17
une victoire qui devrait leur permettre
d'assurer le maintien on écoute le coach
de plaisir sportivement et de par le
travail effectué par les joueurs et tout
le staff et les dirigeants voilà je
pense que c'est tout à fait mérité
c'était vraiment très important
prépare vraiment des choses on s'est
projeté sur plusieurs années donc ouais
c'était vraiment important de se
maintenir cette saison les joueurs sont
très très contents ils ont fait un
week-end très très sérieux puisque on
était quand même partis la veille donc
on avait bien préparé
d'ailleurs je les félicite tous mes
seniors que ce soit la une et la baie
voilà ils ont été vraiment très
professionnelle sur le week end est très
sérieux on l'a vu au classement plaisir
ne devrait donc plus être rejoint dans
ce championnat de fédérale 2 la question
sur ce thème l'équipe de plaisir mérite
t'elle de se maintenir dans ce
championnat
oui ou non oui oui oui on est unanime on
va commencer dans par parfenac reversals
les points ne les ont pas volés on ne
veut dire ils ont ils ont ils ont
remporté des matchs qui était à leur
portée ils ont engrangé les points
qu'ils pouvaient prendre et aujourd'hui
profitent ils profitent du résultat qui
est très certainement un maintien dans
cette dans cette division
donc je pense que oui ils sont à leur
place et on peut leur souhaiter de
continuer leur progression pour espérer
mieux se classer peut-être à l'avenir
pierre le bilan n'est pas trop flatteur
ils sont trois victoires seulement
qu'une début du championnat 13 défaites
est-ce que c'est pas trop flatteur
finalement se maintenant trop flatteur
non non parce que parce que tout le
monde part avec les mêmes les mêmes
conditions au début du championnat on
l'a souvent dit quels que soient les
sports ici
les championnats sont le long des
championnats en poule comme ça en
confrontation directe sont quand même
assez long en matches aller-retour et
fred a raison ils n'ont pas volé leurs
points donc je pense pas que ce soit ce
sera usurpée ils ont ils ont tapé ce
qu'il fallait taper c'est à ceux qui
sont en dessous d'eux maintenant
désormais et d'assurer justement est
assurée d'assurer leur maintien s'est
pas encore totalement faits ils ont mis
une bonne option
et puis je pense qu'ils se sont préparés
pour donc donc comme comme le disait le
l'entraîneur actuel c'est c'était
important que plaisir se maintiennent en
fédérale 2 et d'éviter de faire
l'ascenseur comme ils l'ont déjà fait et
puis c'est bien d'avoir une équipe des
yvelines en fait deux c'est une bonne
chose pour voir si elle aime du coup
c'est le maintien est finalement logique
oui et puis bon de toute façon je pense
qu'il travaille pour pouvoir maintenir
cette place-là en fédérale 2 après dans
les autres matches qu'ils y vont arriver
c'est on leur souhaite de maintenir sa
et de progresser petit à petit à se
faire en un jour
y'a rien quand même voilà des sont quand
même un petit peu son rôle plus loin oui
et puis moi il vient d'arriver mais
voilà il ya du
il ya du travail et mon leur souhaite de
continuer à progresser au moindre ace et
l'appui de continuer à progresser que ça
leur donne confiance pour avancer
jean-françois rien à ajouter non c'est
complètement logique
oui bien sûr parce que l'équipe se soit
ce match et cette saison a pas de
problème genre c'est à vous en tant que
ex coach de plaisir qu'en pensez vous
mais si on reprend les les émissions du
début de saison on avait vu juste
notamment voit toujours juste avant
cette émission nommée notamment moi si
on peut reprendre les enregistrements
j'avais dit que leur principale cible
pour moi dans la poule c'était arras et
d'hautmont et qu'il fallait qu'ils
voient là pour se maintenir un club
lorsqu'il monte sa principale son
principal objectif c'est le maintien
pour la première saison il avait déjà
vécu et était redescendu de suite donc
le fait qu'ils se maintiennent cette
année mais si l'objectif est atteint
largement parce que c'est très difficile
quand on monte de rester et de se
maintenir il en avait déjà fait les
frais donc il ya trois ans oui il ya
trois ans donc de donc le challenge est
réussi ils ont trouvé deux équipes plus
faibles qu'eux ils ont fait ce qu'ils
avaient à faire et donc ils méritent
largement leur maintien après six ans au
delà en partie on va dire c'est grâce
aux adrets leur qui les ont amenés
jusqu'en fédérale 2 à savoir frédéric
jardin et moi même est juste un petit
event et coach pendant pendant deux ans
et de saison j'étais là pour trois
saisons
avec pour objectif de faire monter le
club on a réussi à la montée âne de
saison et j'aurais juste un petit bémol
par rapport au président thierry
l'amendé qui m'a fait un petit article
derrière hommage survie des olympiques
le journal national du rugby et je vois
pas d'ailleurs pourquoi il me tacler la
mesure où je trouve soit l'intervention
sur le journal très incorrect et je
dirais à la nuit tu vraiment
comment non pas diffamatoires n'agirait
pas jusque là mais j'ai ce qu'elle a dit
concrètement donc en 4-4-2 volume
attaché sur le fait que la dernière
fédérale 3 alors qu'on réalise encore
une fois la meilleure saison de
l'histoire du club
j'avais alors j'avais j'aime bien parce
que j'avais on était 2 en valeur il
faudrait que jardé et moi même j'ai
traîné devant fred entraîner derrière
j'avais amené un jeu de vin qu'ils
étaient efficaces qu'ils étaient
efficaces mais qu'était réducteur ou je
sais pas quoi faire donc on réalise une
meilleure saison mais ce monsieur qui à
mon avis est aussi bon président qu'il
est
kylie kylie technicien rugbystique parce
que j'apprécie pas combien convient me
tacler sur ce que j'ai fait qui est bon
en me disant que finalement en
justifiant mon éviction du club en
disant que cette saison mais je n'aurais
pas pu réaliser ça c'est peut-être pas
c'est peut-être pas le niveau de
l'entraîneur actuel et je n'ai
absolument rien contre lesquels je n'ai
absolument rien contre sébastien ou où
ces puits qui l'autre mais j'ai
absolument rien contre eux c'est
plaisant c'est peut-être pas
spécialement les entraîneurs et le fait
que disait amener quelque chose surtout
que déjà nous les amener en fédérale 2
et le fait de me débrouiller pour vous
ça fait trois ans finalement que plaisir
s'apprête à rester en fédérale 2 je
pense qu'on a été
nous nous avons été je dis bien nous
encore et encore une fois fred frais de
jardin et moi même nous avons été les
pierres les pierres de l'édifice qui
aura mené le club en fédérale 2 et ils
ont simplement trouvé deux deux clubs
bien plus faible que pour se maintenir à
plus il va certainement largement être
maintenue puisque la dns âgées du rugby
va accrocher certainement quatre clubs
de fédérale 2 et qui vont redescendre
donc leur maintien est largement acquis
pour moi et sportivement déjà c'est déjà
bien ils on eu besoin d'avoir affaire au
tapis vert pour être maintenus ils ont
fait ce qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient à
faire et il n'y a rien absolument rien à
dire simplement le fait que l'on vienne
me tacler par la bouche du président un
mois sera la question a attiré je jouais
aux joueurs pourquoi ça vient ça vient
là dessus parce qu'il reconnaît d'un
côté que j'avais fait du bon boulot et
en plus venir justifier mon éviction par
rapport à ça c'est pas propre du tout
donc voilà je voulais quand même mettre
les choses au clair
peut être un combat de gladiateurs qui
s'organisera entre vous étirer la mort
jusque là justement le gladiateur il est
là serre chevalier questions réponses à
des jauges en a
as tout à fait raison dans le rugby
amateur c'est les saisons sont
extrêmement longues et faire monter un
club ça prend plusieurs années
dire qu'il faut il faut il faut un vrai
travail est un vrai fond de jeu par
exemple il faut trouver les joueurs et
au niveau amateur
il faut il faut les trouver soit
bénévolement en soi soit on va dire
financièrement mais vraiment le projet
de plaisir à mon sens il a effectivement
trois ans et plus de la première montée
jusqu'à son maintien peut-être pour les
saisons à venir c'est ce qu'on leur
souhaite
mais en tout cas c'est ça n'est pas le
travail que d'un seul ni d'un président
ni ni de ses entraîneurs ni de ses
joueurs
c'est vraiment un travail un travail de
fond pour pouvoir installer un club au
plus haut niveau et évidemment en plus
on monte de deux niveaux en fédérale
plus c'est difficile de se maintenir
donc je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
jean disons que le premier premiers
objectifs d'un club qui vient de monter
c'est de se maintenir
et puis après c'est de travailler dans
la durée pour pouvoir y rester après
cette large page résultats et ce coup de
gueule de genlis nous allons passer à
notre coup de projecteur
dans notre coup de projecteur du golfe
et un come-back celui de tiger woods
l'un des plus grands golfeurs de
l'histoire sera présent fin septembre
sur les greens du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour la ryder cup
l'homme aux 14 grands chelems vient
d'être retenu par le capitaine jim furyk
son ancien coéquipier grand ami pour
être le vice capitaine de l'équipe
américaine face aux joueurs européens
le tigre pourrait toutefois être joueur
sur cette compétition si ces résultats
continuent à s'améliorer on écoute ses
réactions publiées sur les réseaux
sociaux
je précise que tiger woods n'est pas
revenu sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines depuis à 1994 en
tant que joueur comme on peut le voir
sur ces images il avait remporté à
l'époque le championnat du monde amateur
vous avez quelques années de moins la
question sur ce thème cette annonce est
elle une surprise oui ou non vous
d'ailleurs vous de salariés dans quel
est ce que c'est une surprise oui non un
petit duel entre vous et l'aisne et
phonak anderson décidément ll oui à
chercher le dual aujourd'hui j'ai pas
suivi sur sur les années précédentes
enfin les éditions précédentes mais je
pense qu'en vélo dans la seconde oui
voilà
mais je pense que un personnage comme ça
aussi emblématique ses attendus
donc pour moi c'est pas une surprise il
a sa place
il est il représente de golf pour moi
c'est il est attendu et doit être là
quoi qu'il arrive quoi l'a pas emporté
voilà qui soit joueur ou
voilà pour moi c'est voilà l'image
guy golf et white avec anderson va
discuter sur les émissions précédentes
du fait qu'il vienne ou qui ne viennent
pas enfin c'était s'était déjà
intéressante pour le golf que au niveau
de son image qui puisse apporter son
soutien à la compétition après il
restait quand même certaines
incertitudes et c'était pas temps est-ce
qu'il va participer ou non sais plus
quel rôle il va occuper au sein de
l'équipe américaine est ce qu'ils se
rassurent en retrait est ce qui fera
partie des joueurs et on voit que c'est
encore une question qui est en suspens
donc il reste encore un peu
d'incertitude autour de ce point là mais
je pense que c'est une bonne chose pour
l'instant il est vice capitaine
mais s'ils arrivent à améliorer ses
résultats il sera dans l'équipe donc
espérons pour l'événement qui soit un
joueur parce que c'est vrai que tiger
woods joueurs saluaient même dimension à
c'est toujours mieux que que tiger woods
le spectateur ou encadrant images pour
vous pierre chevalier
c'est ce qui va être déterminant
avec la présence de tailleur à saint
quentin il y avait deux manières de
l'accueillir dans l'équipe américaine
soit choisie comme vice capitaine par
furic soit soit dans les points pour
rentrer pour entrer dans l'équipe
tiger woods dans l'histoire et pas
forcément le meilleur équipier en ryder
cup c'est pas c'est pas forcément les
meilleurs résultats
ce soit en simple ont semblé en ryder
cup 7 33 matches 13 victoires 17
défaites et trois nuls
voilà il s'est donc c'est le côté c'est
le côté peut-être le revers de la
médaille et le côté individuel du golfe
mais donc ce n'est pas forcément le
meilleur équipier à côté de st dans ce
qu'il tracte et ce qu'il apporte en
termes d'image à la fois pour l'équipe
américaine faire douter l'équipe
européenne et surtout pour le golf au
niveau mondial par rapport à tout ce
qu'il a apporté à ce sport et on l'a dit
on l'a souvent dit dans cette émission
en ayant à la fois à la fois raison est
peut-être le petit coup d'oeil
visionnaire et puis le le le
la reconnaissance de ce que fait
d'ailleurs route au niveau mondial furic
je pense lui c'est une petite fleur il
vient d'où il vient de redémarrer de
redémarrer de recommencer à jouer ils
recommencent pas trop mal joué ils
gagnent pas encore l'air notamment
réalisé une très belle 12e place aux
honda classic qui est l'un des meilleurs
tournois exactement américain du dernier
mon nom furie que je pense lui enlève
une partie de pression en lui disant tu
seras tu seras la ryder cup qui sera
vice capitaine si ça peut te permets de
délier un petit peu et puis de rentrer
dans les points de scorer et de
remporter des tournois pour être dans
l'équipe
là on aura tout gagné mais au moins on a
cette certitude pour le golf français et
international que tiger sera à saint
quentin et ça c'est une énorme nouvelle
gens me sais ce que c'est pas un peu du
copinage on peut le dire jim furyk et
tiger woods se connaissent depuis de
nombreuses années est-ce qu'il fallait
le prendre malgré tout mais tiger woods
c'est ce que je vais dire d'une émission
précédente
tiger woods s'est s'est associé au golf
aujourd'hui on parle de golf
même ceux qui s'y connaissent pas on va
vous parler de ta god
donc c'est au niveau au niveau image
et développement du golf chez nous en
plus c'est primordial pour moi c'est son
questionnaire ne pas l'avoir apporté
j'aurai une fois les professionnels
parce que là on ne parle pas on parle
pas de qualité de jeu on parle d'image
dont il ya l'image d'un côté et
l'ajustement je pense que le responsable
a quand même voilà il est quand même
lucides en dix ans et je t'amène vice
capitaine mais si si vraiment
sportivement tu peux apporter
et tu rentreras dans l'équipe donc moi
je trouve au contraire c'est très très
bien très bien jaugé parce que il sait
que mais comme ça la main sur un tournoi
comme ça au niveau psychologique ça peut
faire douter l'europe ça peut amener un
plus énorme à la discipline parce que
c'est quand même un monsieur un monsieur
du golfe moi je l'avais dit dans une
émission du 10 mai - tiger woods s'est
et il n'y a pas en lui avant c'était
ballesteros c'était moi dans ma tête et
c'est lé plus grand golfeur que je
connaissais et donc forcément ce qu'il a
il a joué à vraiment dans tous les
domaines et en plus il s'est réservé une
porte de sortie à 10 ans tu peux être
oughlis capitaine ou si tu as les
résultats sportifs que tu peux amener tu
seras ma roussillon au pire des cas il
pourrait organiser des soirées
en tout cas on a compris un genre sera
avec son carnet d'autographes devant le
golf national en cet an prochain budget
mais moi j'irai chez les noirs tiger
woods avoir le même genre de choix à
faire thomas bjorn dans son dans son
choix de vice-capitaine va se poser la
question prendre un français par exemple
un des deux français il ya des trois
français qui ont participé à rider
qu'elle se soit van de velde relevé par
exemple
ou ou d'accorder des wild cards ou
scruter le niveau des français pour pour
avoir un français sur la première haider
cup organisée sur le sol français
donc elle vieillit thomas ce but on va
avoir à peu près le même le même genre
de question à se poser c'est bien nous
qui n'a pas encore tranché
voilà jean françois guy borrel non si si
je peux me permettre je sais pas si je
vais conclure mais c'est vrai que non
non non si pour moi je lui conclure sur
la façon dont tout à l'heure on a parlé
de popularité de popularité
concernant les différents ce soit le
cyclisme le tennis est là je crois que
tiger woods se fait pour que la ryder
cup soit populaire et là je crois que
les gens vont être étonnés même en
france parce qu'à la ryder cup ces jeux
s'est passé 81 80 milles 80000 personnes
qui vont savez de 65 65 par jour et
comment va faire on est au niveau haut
niveau le golf national art très bien
fait pour ça notamment pour sur tout les
buts qui est qui borde le parcours pour
pouvoir voir bien de partout et puis a
maintenant toutes les intrigues est
l'infrastructure qui se passe quand
c'est la siac tour de france c'est au
tour de france
dernière question sur cette thématique
tiger woods se peut-il combiner les deux
casquettes joueur et capitaine d'un x ça
avait été fait par arnold palmer lors de
la ryder cup en 1963
les usa l'avait emporté contre la grande
bretagne 23 à 9
comme quoi on peut faire vice capitaine
et joueur est ce que ça peut être
possible aussi pour tiger woods pourquoi
pas il nous donnera la réponse déjà je
pense que la première étape c'est
d'obtenir les résultats qui lui
permettront d'accrocher une place de
titulaire dans l'équipe je pense que
c'est surtout salle à la première
question à qui il va falloir répondre à
partir de là c'est la réalité du terrain
qui va parler après c'est juste le
talent et la qualité de jeu qui qui fera
oui ou non est ce qu'ils ont fait est ce
que tiger woods a réussi à déjouer et
être plus capitaine avec succès lors de
cet événement pour vos pieds relance qui
arrive je dirais non c'est pas dans sa
nature
c'est pas dans sa nature si jamais il
est dans l'équipe ça il va se concentrer
sur ses sur cd double et c'est simple il
ya suffisamment monde autour
simple jury n'a perdu qu'une seule fois
en selle mais cela c'est là c'est un
match qui doit donc je pense je pense
pas qu'ils puissent faire les deux
qu'ils aient envie de faire les deux
après je me garderai bien de d'être dans
la tête de tiger woods mais non je pense
pas je pense pas qu'il fait qu'il est à
faire les deux genres par contre
sélectionneur il s'appelle coin mais
c'est que faire une jam furic halo
capitaine achab urnes
thomas scott thomas c'est pour ça qu'il
a pris de la face à cette thématique
c'est un coup de projecteur passe
maintenant notre focus du jour focus sur
les jo de 2024 à paris la compétition se
prépare déjà au niveau des instances six
ans avant l'événement planétaire
l'athlète paralympique maintenant à
keita championne du 400 mètres
malvoyants à rio en 2016 et ans et
ancien athlète de l'eau à saint quentin
en yvelines va intégrer le comité
d'organisation des jeux de 2024 la
sportive qui travaille toujours à
montigny le bretonneux chez malakoff
médéric vient d'être désigné par le
président tony estanguet dans ce comité
siègera aux côtés de l'ancien athlète
marie et josé pérec du biathlète martin
fourcade de l'ancien tennisman guy
forget et de la boxeuse de sarah
ourahmoune les athlètes participeront
notamment aux grandes phases de
planification leur sort en dévot
olympique parisien la question sur ce
thème l'arrivée de l'antenne à quetta et
tel renfort de poids dans l'organisation
des jo de 2024
je pense que tout sera unanime
j'ai en face à guy borrel pour une fois
je crois que les tony estanguet a suivi
c'est à dire que maintenant les jeux
olympiques c'est reflète vraiment le
fait que les que les cycles afin que les
parents les sportifs prennent le pouvoir
enfin c'est il suivit vienne et alors
qu'avant c'était très politique ça reste
politique mais je pense que c'est bon
qu'il y ait des athlètes en eau est là
aussi vous êtes d'accord
oui ou non mais c'est vrai
non je suis oui mais voilà oui donc
volontairement keita voilà 33 en trois
olympiades à 10,15 2008 selon lui 12 et
rio en 2016
les performances qu'elle fait allégeance
à ce comité
pour moi il a tout à fait sa place à des
jets avec des générations différentes
elle représente assez bien donc oui ce
genre pour vous alors oui je dirai oui
j'y mets juste un petit bémol parce que
personnellement je la connais pas après
je vais au niveau d'une médaille d'or
sur le 400 m avec york 16 h 30 à sion je
suis pas non plus mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut il faut quand même pour un comité
d'organisation n'est les images du sport
français je ne dénigre surtout pas parce
que je voudrais pas qu'un comme plus ils
m'attaquent et vous avez un contrat il
plaisir à sur le dos depuis sa déjà très
content du tout mais non mais non mais
sinon je dis simplement senti simplement
que au niveau image pour moi j'y mets
juste un bémol mais d'un autre côté
c'est pour ça que j'ai répondu oui parce
que c'est bien aussi de ne pas prendre
que des gens connus sportivement de tout
le monde et que ouvre alors peut-être
mal le prendre parce que lire et ricker
championne du monde c'est un champion
olympique donc bon mais c'est vrai qu'il
faut reconnaître que j'ai pas si
quelqu'un autour de la table la connaît
mais
personnellement je ne la connais pas
jamais de lui parler donc j'y mets juste
mais molle mais de notre côté c'est un
plus aussi parce que mais il s'est sans
cadrer de personnes aussi qu'ils ne sont
pas médiatisés et ça c'est bien 33 33
est ce qu'elle est quand même assez
jeune elle pas encore concourir
c'est ça encore faudrait qu'un personnes
je pense que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle parce que c'est vrai qu'on a
souvent tendance à oublier que je vous
en prie que ceux ci les jeux
paralympiques qui vont avec c'est vrai
que on revient un peu à l'histoire de la
médiatisation ou on n'en parle pas assez
clairement
après le gros avantages qu'elle apporte
au dossier c'est qu'elle a déjà vécu les
olympiades un réseau de pays donc elle
et elle est consciente des limites et
des problèmes qu'ont déjà été rencontrés
en plus comme elle est française va le
connaît aussi déjà là la situation pas
catastrophique un peu d'aidé du handicap
en france la réalité des personnes
handicapées au delà du sport même qu'au
niveau nivôse et accessibilité des des
infrastructures etc
je pense qu'elle va pouvoir vraiment
montré du doigt les problèmes à résoudre
pour que les jeux olympiques et surtout
paralympiques qui vont suivre derrière
soi un succès et éventuellement si c'est
un beau succès peut-être qu'elle aura
aussi le supplément de médiatisation qui
qu'il est totalement digitimes pour ces
athlètes qui sont aussi des athlètes de
haut niveau et qui sont aussi au plus
haut niveau de du sport d'élite dans
cette prise de pouvoir des sportifs de
la famille olympique n'oublie personne
et c'est très bien d'avoir ce d'avoir
une représentation de sportifs par des
politiciens
oui oui oui oui je les folies pour
l'image qu'on veut donner qu'on veut
donner aux jo de paris 2024 c'est
globalement la meilleure caution qui
soit ce sont des ce sont des sportifs
qui ont qui ont connu les jeux qui ont
des titres
et qui seront exactement quoi conseiller
quoi faire pour que pour que les gillou
2024 à paris souhaite une vraie fête est
une vraie réussite jeux paralympiques
seront organisées du 28 août au 9
septembre à paris en passe maintenant à
notre rubrique débats
il faut remonter à mars 2005 pour
observer un tel phénomène une vague de
froid a traversé la france cet hiver
avec des températures négatives et des
ressentis pour antal et jusqu'à -10
degrés dans la région un facteur avec
lequel les joueurs ont dû composer ce
week-end le week-end sur le terrain pour
ne pas se blesser surtout pour ramener
la victoire à la fin du match c'est
notamment le cas des templiers
d'elancourt de fallait qu anderson qui
ont essayé de se à réchauffer comme il
le pouvait sur les terrains pendant les
matchs en utilisant un chauffage
électrique pendant la rencontre on
écoute la réaction d'un joueur forcément
le froid on a les mains qui frise et
pour attraper de balancer un petit peu
moins facile mais certaines parties du
jeu ça sent trop le pas donc il faut
faire avec c'est au fallait qu'un
personne ça vient d'où ce chauffage
électrique au bord du terrain
ça vient du style et des noms n'avaient
en avait déjà eu la gym des problèmes
dans d'anticiper le froid et qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait faire pour essayer bas de
d'alléger un peu le fardeau que ça
représente pour les joueurs rester chaud
sur la touche c'est vrai que hall a
rajouté une ou deux couches de vêtements
peut pas faire grand chose et c'est vrai
que a rajouté une paire de chaussettes
chose extrémités enfin les extrémités
c'est toujours compliqué à réchauffer
quel que soit dit souvent aussi n'ont
donc c'est vrai que brawn a fait avec le
système d est ce qu'on avait sous la
main et qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire
pour essayer d'améliorer un peu qu'on
force la touche après on vous prend dans
un dom on joue pas en intérieur ou en
extérieur en fait quelle condition qu'il
y ait une façon les joueurs ont déjà vu
pire genre ces bonnes idées
ah ah oui réchauffe les extrémités ç'a
toujours été de folie
ça c'est sûr non mais c'est vrai mais
non mais non mais non mais après ça me
surprend un freshman c'est la première
fois que vous voyez ça j'espère que
pouvaient profiter parfois des
commerçants non mais je réside ou est-ce
enfin joaillier ça parce que le rugby
rugby on est quand même et je pense
qu'on ne touche plus le ballon
on touche beaucoup plus le ballon deux
fois que les ricains et sochaux faut pas
les mais on n'a pas de gaz n'a rien du
tout voilà donc ça vous surprend un
petit peu quand même vie que frédéric
ont fait des gains de plus ils vont
partir donc donc je rends compte pour le
tacler mais ça me surprend pas le chemin
ça va surprendre dans la mesure où c'est
pour moi c'est un petit et un petit peu
mais contre contre-pied du c'était bien
le chauffer les vimynois qui sont sur le
banc bon en fait comme c'est un sport de
spécialistes là c'est salissant ce pas
voilà j'y rentre sur le terrain je pense
que c'est plus je pense que c'est plus
frédéric qui a demandé un petit
chauffage ont approuvé pour lui et
joueurs ont cru qu'on sent que je suis
voila voila je passe alors alors le
lendemain les températures tombent à
moins à 3 degrés en plein après midi sur
le stade gilles marchand sac de trappes
pour combattre le froid les joueurs ont
élaboré des stratégies on regarde le
cyclisme on ne la crème meuse ou pas
yukiko locaux papa morceaux et tout ça
c'est plus qu'une au match pour l'apa
croit jean-françois ces nouvelles
stratégies
oui mais c'est vrai que comme disait
jean ils sortent du vestiaire il joue
lorsque vous faites 200 km à vélo je
parle de vélo sur avec la pluie froid
pendant paris-nice
maintenant il ya des gants en néoprène
mais j'ai connu une époque on mettait du
du papier journal au bout des pieds à
l'interné chaussures ce que les
chausseurs avait des petits trous donc
papier journal tout trempé les cuissards
en laine je vous dis pas dix kilos de
plus d'annoncés tu es et l élégant dans
les années 80 dans les 80 s était pas de
néoprène n'y avait pas le lycra
c'est vraiment faire 180 km faire six
heures de vélo sous la flotte sous la
neige et c'est autrement difficile mais
c'est vrai que c'est très dur d'avoir
france port ça c'est mes shows aussi
pour qu'ils ont ils pu faire la même
chose
l'alpe d'huez avec 40 degrés c'est pas
évident on plaide pour une stratégie
l'ont fait à trappes
oui toute façon le froid dans le froid
c'est l'enfer implique de toutes façons
de 10 au dessus
non non mais toute façon tout ce qui
peut rendre les conditions moins
difficiles
et entre guillemets plus agréable il
faut quand même il faut quand même bien
je trouvais des faut quand même trouver
des solutions c'est après ces questions
nous c'est pas compatible mais il ya de
plus en plus de moyens techniques que ce
soit les verts mais par exemple rugby au
foot il ya des terrains synthétiques il
ya des vêtements techniques maintenant
donc être plus en plus de moyens de
contourner cette tâche et froid mais sur
le papier c'est pas très complet donc
c'est compatible sa dépense salle
devient salle de vie les échauffements
ci sont ils importants du mondial sont
bien sûr c'est primordial et rythme que
l'on faisait pas dans les étirements
après primordial avec anderson vous avez
fait un échauffement c'est ça pendant la
mi temps juste avant la reprise de la
seconde période devant le toile
évidemment parce que de toute façon on a
besoin de m'échauffer la température du
corps pour avoir un la meilleure
performance tu aussi parce que plusieurs
adaptations qui prennent qui prennent
place avec l'augmentation de la
température des muscles les muscles sont
plus capables de capter l'oxygène par
exemple du coup il fonctionne beaucoup
mieux
la température des muscles s'élève donc
du coup les ligaments qui sont autour
des propriétés biomécanique s'améliore
aussi donc si on va avoir une
performance optimale c'est vrai que
l'échauffement est vraiment est vraiment
important alors si certains ont peur de
faire du sport sous des températures
glaciales
d'autres au contraire la recherche vous
propose de découvrir la méthode
wemhoff du nom d'un néerlandais sur le
mais l'homme de glace
le concept les débutants doivent
apprendre à maîtriser leur corps pour
accepter le froid avec des respirations
explications avec mathieu sachets à
l'instructeur originaire de versailles
résiste pas
on rentre dans l'eau il ya une attitude
dans les pensées d'une attitude
corporelle relâcher les épaules il ya
une attitude à travers la respiration
c'est à dire si on rentre dans l'eau
sans entraînement on va être
complètement paniqué c'est à dire que le
cerveau passer en mode peurs primales on
peut par le contrôle de la respiration
reprendre le contrôle
voilà et
et calmer le jeu pour que le corps
s'adapte et laisse faire ce qu'il faut
c'est une réaction gens font ça guy
borrel non mais je pense qu'il a raison
et la raison mais faut voir le faire et
savoir le faire et puis puis c'est une
fille je pensais c'est une philosophie c
est certain à l'onf et par conséquent
donc on peut courir dans le froid sous
la neige on peut également se baigner à
saint quentin en yvelines ce jeudi 8
mars où les températures de 6 degrés en
extérieur avec du vent des têtes brûlées
ou plutôt des athlètes confirmés se sont
testés sous l'eau après à plusieurs
exercices de respiration ils sont restés
dans l'eau pendant plusieurs minutes
on écoute leur sortie de ce sportif ce
qu'on ressent ce que c'est justement le
fait qu'on soit focalisée sur son
souffle vata m en fait d'apprécier
bizarrement le côté vivifiant de l'eau
et le côté froid donc elle est vraiment
forte tu te sens on le sent tout de
suite aux extrémités c'est ça le le
premier point faible entre guillemets en
fait qu'on va avoir cédé activité que ce
soit les pieds les mains
alors évidemment ce type de performance
n'est pas à reproduire sans un
entraînement confirmés et sans
autorisation une réaction
photo s'étale en jambes ouais c'est le
jeune femme cachée de 1,8 shao et pato
bennoo est une question sérieuse
est-ce qu'on a des images montrant que
voilà michael a essayé moi je filme je
n'essaye pas y avait passé une bonne
soirée
non mais faut voir après donc on va voir
comment comment comment la
professionnelle c'est sûrement
après il l'assimilé maîtrise mme après
il ya souvent des tremblements en fait
voilà c'est fait en bougeant mais quel
moment quels intérêts oui quel est
intérêt c'est augmenter sa résistance au
froid immunitaire également au cas où on
tombe l'oms a dans sa permet également
de tomber moins malade par exemple c'est
vrai c'est une performance bien sûr je
pense pas que ce soit une discipline
sportive comme on en découvre beaucoup
sur ce plateau
mais la performance est notable le
respect respect pour ces faux
scandinaves qui si bon frileux avec
hammerson look est un peu le
scientifique ridicule et dangereux pour
un droit parce que le risque
d'hypothermie et réelle donc on a beau
se retrouvèrent loi mettra vous avez
vraiment un avis tranché que je vois je
vois pas l'intérêt de voir faire ça il
faut aussi mettre en garde si vous êtes
kazakhs des problèmes de coeur c'est
vraiment examen il faut que nous l'avons
questionnaire médical avant de pratiquer
cette performance des problèmes quand on
rentre dans l'eau et qu'elle est aussi
froide que ça tous les vaisseaux
sanguins de la peau et des extrémités
bon beat furrer permet pas aux
constructions
du coup leurs frissons gains vers le
coeur augmente la de la pression
sanguine crève le plafond et c'est vrai
que c'est parra que certains souffrent
d' arrêt cardiaque et donc à ce que ça
vaut le coup de risquer sa santé pour ça
surtout que les effets supposés sur le
système immunitaire etc n'ont jamais été
prouvées et n'ont jamais été confirmées
je pense que c'est une prise de risque
inutile
je vois pas l'intérêt ou jour toujours
se mouiller la nuque et atteint deux
heures après
surtout aussi manger avec anderson par
exemple les nouvelles méthodes de
récupération utilise le froid c'est pas
pareil de moins en moins au compteur
j'irai aussi des sportifs et bien
souvent dans des bains glacés renard
alias al'avantage également avec du
froid c'est pour tout ce qui est coup ça
permet ça permet de faire passer la
douleur surtout c'est surtout l'aspect
douleur et sauf que ça dure c'est un
laps de temps très court
très très peu il rentre dans le lot je
n'ai pas très envie c'est d'y rester
trop longtemps possible à 5 minutes
c'est trop et puis un autre aspect aussi
du froid c'est que on s'est rendu compte
que ça ça ralentissait pas tous les
processus de cicatrisation et de
récupération
enfin certains d'entre eux même si on
améliore d'autres donc c'est il ya des
avantages et des inconvénients
on s'est rendu compte maintenant par
exemple sur les sur les entorses ont
fait plus le protocole rails sont faits
plus le protocole repos donc le reste à
ce propos la zl1 sans pression c'est à
eux et l'évêché et débat sur le sens le
fait plus maintenant on conseille
d'aller voir le kiné le kiné fait des
exercices particuliers pour recharger
les tendons et leur permettent de
progressivement se sont-ils on sache
elle le processus donc très bien cinq
instructeurs en france 150000 à 200000
personnes qui le teste dans le monde
cette méthode est généralement ça se
pratique aux pays bas aux états unis en
australie et combien de grossesse
combien de décès n'enlèvera pas les
chiffres abbayes normandes pays
nordiques recherche de sensations et de
performance personnelle de voir mais il
ya des femmes qui font ça parce qu'il ya
un côté très cinglant 2 testé un peu
jusqu'où on peut aller et ses lèvres
gercées
alors je ne peux pas cautionner ce de
leur équipe qui je vis un carton jaune
on va maintenant de cette émission on
ouvre notre page découverte sport
insolite à présent direction vélizy
villacoublay à présent les championnats
de france de bras de fer était organisée
ce samedi 3 mars dans la ville pour la
quatrième fois représentation de cette
discipline qui compte une soixantaine de
licenciés en île de france par le
président de la fédération française au
micro de nicolas douchez
on insiste bien sur le terme de bras de
fer sportif pas du bras de fer de
comptoir pour vos poignets soit bien
droit que votre 14 soit en fait je vous
ayez l'épaule bien en face que vous
soyez dans l'axé médian de la table et
ce n'est pas qu'une question de force
comme nous l'expliquent le président de
la fédération française
la force est au service de la technique
et non la force qui remplace la
technique vous avez des gens qui pour
d'autres disciplines sont des gens très
puissants mais quand vous les mettez sur
table de braqueurs ils ont un petit
niveau de résistance mais apprennent ils
n'ont pas la technique ils sont un peu
perdus une réaction autour de cette
table
genre je me sens inspirée cette émission
vous qui êtes un adepte du bras de fer a
tout à fait raison
la force c'est surtout la technique la
force c'est bien mais surtout la
technique
la technique est plus moi moi pour moi
c'est un sport qui est complètement
et là je vais juste à fêter sur le
chemin de frédéric mais il va le dire
mais bon c'est c'est un bras pour une
finale et lacées haut niveau au niveau
physiologique physiologie et physionomie
et j'ai pour moi c'est pas bon c'est
bien le spectacle mais ont cédé paris à
quoi ça sert ce qu'on a c'est un sport
mais j'ai la différence au niveau au
niveau physique frédéric je pense que
c'est jamais bossé froid je me suis
jamais tenant je sais sûrement pcc
vraiment que d'un côté ou ce travail
voire musculaire et posé une colle après
j'ai décollé jeudi collet il ya un peu
les mêmes les mêmes préoccupations sur
javelot sur mort de tous les sports
unilatéraux 1 quand on regarde un
tennisman layrac donc je suis contre
l'autre ouais parce que là c'est mc cain
la force obscure la puissance c'est
qu'elle est donc finalement ce sont pas
les structures les plus gros biceps nord
il ya une technique nick de la technique
la technique est plein de chasse d'eau
c'est la vitesse la vitesse est
l'impression aussi que j'ai peur que tu
cites et qu' il ya vraiment quelqu'un 15
membres qui travaillent ils tuent ne
peut pas à l'entraînement travail est
autre chose que la musculature des bras
gauche
quelle que soit la manière mais c'est
pas le seul sport où il ya comme un veau
guidera et j'ai quand même cette
question donc du coup c'est bête mais ok
il ya un bras qui travaillent mais du
coup tu es ce que en compétition tout le
monde est droitier forcément comment
faire autrement jamais change en
fonction des droitiers ou gauchers
nous n'avons pas forcément à gauche et
s'ils ont débauché on est à droite chez
qu'un championnat de france deux
droitiers gens bien que j'en voyais les
catégories hommes femmes également des
matches où soderling
je suis tombé il ya quand même intérêt
quand même c'est un vrai sport bien sûr
bien sûr il faut une préparation il faut
tout y est
fisico sa passion et l'énergie je serai
l'énergie que si j'ai la tactique la
technique et la tactique c'est
primordial et il ya une préparation à la
moi je la respecte et j'y vais pas me
frotter et il n'y a que 200 licenciés en
france mais rentrer dans les yvelines
jean-françois libre à 30 30 dans les
yvelines dans quel club 30 alors
d'enlever l'isi année li zhi 60 en ile
de france et 200 en france parce qu'ils
portent sur ces compétitions je dis bien
commencé voici salle quelle est la
démarche en soirée tiens tiens secondes
devant toi tu fais la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent le jeudi 22 mars
pour une nouvelle émission va terminer
par une citation d'un footballeur qui a
brillé en ligue des champions cette
semaine avec le real madrid cristiano
ronaldo les buts c'est comme le ketchup
quand ils arrivent ils viennent tous en
même temps je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]